they get it to Davis right back to Lomax
16 seconds left your foul guys
Davis with nine seconds he tripped to
the ground a scramble Memphis has it and
they call a tie up and the arrow favors
the owls
Memphis was trying to get a timeout
Hardaway was on the ground but instead
of a timeout it's a tie up and now the
owls call a timeout with five seconds on
the clock I mean what a bad turnover by
Memphis really and surprisingly that FAU
didn't foul right away it was only 17
seconds to go you're down one you have
to foul and this is just a really bad
turnover he left his feet
and take a look at the end of this play
because Penny Hardaway was asking his
son Jaden did you try to call timeout
you see lofax was trying to call a
timeout yeah they did try but this is
something that's not reviewable
you're gonna see it right here
right on the ground Jaden Hardaway oh
yeah Davis and Lomax on Memphis both
trying to call time out but it wasn't
granted and instead the tie up with the
possession arrow favoring
[Applause]
here's Boyd five seconds left boy drives
with 2.5
Lomax at Mid Court McCannon doesn't get
it off and the owls Win It
[Applause]
the first NCAA tournament win in Florida
Atlantic history and it comes in
dramatic fashion over Memphis
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
a little boy made a great play because
instead of just firing it up he knows
the best thing to do is to drive it and
maybe get a foul he just lays it in the
basket no help comes comes very late
just a great play by Boyd
the reaction from the FAU bench
[Applause]
and then Lomax had it at Mid Court
didn't have enough time to pass to
mccadden right there there's only one
second left and mccadden doesn't get it
off in time he needed to shoot that from
half court I mean obviously it wasn't
going to be a great one but he needed to
shoot that
[Applause]
32nd win of the year for the owls and
the reaction of the Memphis bench Penny
Hardaway Chucks his water bottle
just a stunning defeat
as we go over to Jamie Erdahl I'm
letting these two guys have a moment
Nick just like you droed up huh walk us
through that last play man I told Coach
I got it give me the ball and um he
drove a great play I showed it he jumped
he's got to the rim I don't know I can't
really explain I'm just having fun uh I
gotta thank God but I've Been Waiting
For a Moment Like This my whole life
just jumped on a table after an NCAA
tournament win is this everything that
you have worked for in your life most
definitely I'm in the gym every day you
know it's beautiful I don't know I just
got to thank God this coach Smiles at
you guys and every time out what does
that mean in terms of confidence in a
game like this man I don't know where
I'll be without this guy for real
alone
coach
I observed you in your huddles you're
smiling at these guys at times this game
was so tough to play and what was it
like to coach him well I have a lot of
faith in our guys they put in the work
they're they're together they've done
this all season even on nights when a
lot went wrong they stayed the course
and believed in each other and they made
some big time plays you've been at this
program now you've been building it
building it why was this team the one to
get this first win in NCAA tournament
leadership in our locker room these guys
they they hold each other accountable uh
into a very high standard as well just a
special group of people
you know that fdu team beat Purdue just
before you what'd you watch from that
game what do you know about this team I
know they play really hard and they
believe it's going to be a great game
just like a team that you played pretty
hard against good luck or
congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
f-a-u will take